Do you have a friend who just…
INHALES their food?
You know what I mean?
Like, you've had one bite and THEIR WHOLE
BURRITO IS GONE?
What are you doing, man?
Did you even taste it?
Turns out, she probably didn't.
foodies
Food is incredible. I love it. I love to eat
it, I love to cook it, I love shopping for
the ingredients!
There's nothing worse than spending hours
shopping, prepping, cooking, and serving,
just to have someone scarf it in three bites
in seconds. And a new study confirms what
I'd knew in my foodie heart… people who
eat super fast, don't taste their food; not
really, anyway.
The study was published in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences under
the appetizing title, "Optimal directional
volatile transport in retronasal olfaction,"
because science, while great at mise en place,
has no sense of presentation. Translating
the title into layman: they wanted to know
how smells got to our nose, from the outside
or the INSIDE. And their study found, the
latter was actually more important. Our tongue
tastes five (maybe six) flavors, but food
can have any number of smells to add to those
perceptions!
Using a model of the human mouth, throat and
nasal cavities, researchers found when we
inhale through the nose, we create an "air
curtain" which keeps volatile -- or airborne
-- molecules from going into the lungs. But,
when we exhale, food volatiles trapped in
the back of the throat swirl upward into the
nasal cavity, where we sense them with our
olfactory systems!
If you eat fast, the air curtain doesn't form,
the volatiles don't have time to get trapped
in the back of your throat, and thus you don't
smell and taste together!
There's definitive science for slowing down
to savor a meal, for sure.
Sometimes, you just want a good scarf, a satisfying
guzzling of comforting carbohydrates can make
us feel really good once in a rare while,
but making a habit of it is the dangerous.
This MAY be supported by a 2006 study of nearly
5000 people in the Journal of Epidemiology
which found, the rate of food intake heavily
correlated with rate of obesity!
And another study in the Journal of American
Dietetic Association discovered, when people
eat fast, they take in more calories, but
feel less satisfaction from their meal!
If you look at how complicated our alimentary
canal really is, this makes more than a mouthful
of sense.
The stomach is a highly connected organ in
the human body. It has a direct connection
along the vagus nerve right to the brain stem.
When you put food in your belly, the stomach
has mucosa and muscles which detect the mechanical
feel and overall volume of food, as well as
how much the stomach compressed or stretched.
When it's empty, a hormone called ghrelin
is secreted -- called the hunger hormone,
to trigger appetite. Once you eat, the stomach
stretches, and ghrelin is suppressed; causing
your vagus nerve to signal your brain stem…
and that signal tells the intestinal train
to get moving!
Obviously, this is SUPER simplified, there
are hormones, enzymes and nerves being tripped
and squirted all over the tube running through
the middle of your body, but like that corn
you ate yesterday… let's try to get through
this in one piece.
Next, food moves into the intestine and another
hormone called leptin comes into the picture.
Leptin is one piece of the nutrient satiation
puzzle, the idea that what you're eating has
fulfilled your body's nutritional requirement.
Scientists don't entirely understand the whole
thing, but they know, as food continues through
the system, the ileum, colon and rectum will
cause secretion of MORE hormones called PYY.
A 2006 study found, when mice were deprived
of PYY, they wouldn't control their intake,
and became obese!
So scientists figure, PYY (along with all
these other hormones, nerves and triggers)
eventually work together to tell your brain
OKAY Y'ALL. WE'RE GOOD DOWN HERE. STOP EATING.
[[whew!!]]
Complicated, no?
It's important to be cognizant of the fact,
humans are not robots. Many people try and
control every aspect of their lives, including
eating to take in calories, but being mindful
of WHAT you're eating, is just as important
as HOW you're eating. When we eat like a machine,
our body doesn't have time to suppress or
secrete these myriad of compounds, or trigger
these processes. It takes time for this sack
of meat to know when it's got food in it!
So, science says it's best to eat slowly.
You'll taste your food better, you'll decrease
your portion sizes, and feel better about
what you've eaten!
You might even lose weight!
Don't eat TOO slow… if you eat so slow that
you stop eating altogether you'd eventually
die. Eventually… ever curious about what
would happen in between?
So was I!
How long could we survive without food or
water?
Don't worry, we DNewsed
it.
Do you eat fast?
Why?
Don't tell me you're punching your brother
or sister for a seat at the table. Think about
it for a second and answer with something
introspective, why do you think eat at the
speed you eat?